in about an hour from now president
trump will head back to the white house
from walter reed medical center
his doctors say he's doing much better
but is not fully recovered
it is unclear right now when the
president will resume campaigning
now that's either virtually or in person
meanwhile
vice president joe biden the former vice
president i should say is back on the
campaign trail and reacting
to some of the latest news i was glad
to see the president speaking and
recording videos over the weekend now
that he's busy tweeting campaign
messages i would ask him to do this
listen to the scientists support
mass dana uh
the president i think by everybody's
account had a
tumultuous week last week with the
raucous debate performance and then
contracting covet and now the national
polls the first one done
afterwards wall street journal has biden
ahead by
14 points and we don't know when the
president gets back on the campaign
trail what do you see well a lot of
those were also
they were taken after the debate and i
think you know i think that the debate
didn't go as well as the president's
team said that it did for them in terms
of
audience reaction or battleground
reaction but in terms of the
battleground states
those polls are still actually fairly
tight and you have a situation for
example in north carolina i know that
vice presidents in florida today there
are some who think north carolina
is as vital as pennsylvania the
democrat in the senate race for example
has been running way far ahead of
senator tillis but all of a sudden over
the weekend something that didn't get a
lot of attention it turns out that not
only was he
sexting with one mistress but now
there's a second mistress
and he pulled out of a campaign event
today
and so you could start to see that
there's a possibility within the next 30
days
that a state like north carolina instead
of being
you know just with biden slightly ahead
maybe the you know maybe there's a way
to close that gap
and then the turnout we know what
enthusiasm is going to be for president
trump i don't know if it'll be the same
for joe biden
it will be the highest turnout election
that we've ever had
i i believe in history all right so
let's pick up on that jesse because what
dana's talking about so critical
battleground states
and the new york times siena poll has
him the
uh vice former vice president biden up
by eight
in uh arizona cbs has biden up by
seven in pennsylvania and the thing that
struck me about arizona is trump is
losing in maricopa county which you
would think is a strong
republican uh you know base he's not
losing in maricopa county and he won't
lose in maricopa county they're out
registering democrats by the hundreds of
thousands in maricopa county
he will win arizona i don't believe that
poll for a minute i don't believe the 14
point deficit either
that was a d9 poll they interviewed
under a thousand people
registered voters a month away from the
election i wouldn't run a poll like that
everybody knows that's not true
joe biden took the weekend off a month
out think about it he called lids on
saturday and sunday morning
what is that i guess you could just take
the weekend off and let the media
campaign forum
but that that wasn't good i'm i think
the president he's got a strong digital
team he's a great community
communicator the whole family can get
out and hit the battlegrounds
i'm not worried about it at all he knew
the risks he assessed the risks he was
comfortable with the risk getting out
there
in terms of the coronavirus and he
understands it
a part of the job as president you
cannot hide in the basement
for months and let other people do
frontline duties
he's an essential worker he happened to
catch the virus
he's recovering hopefully and it's going
to go well and he's going to come back
and i think he's going to beat sleepy
hard in november
all right greg i was thinking the
president i remember he was making fun
of hillary clinton when she had
pneumonia and the like
but now people are saying maybe there's
a sympathy vote out there
for the president what do you think it
could happen i i do want to point out
that
for some reason everybody in the media
just chooses that poll
and there was another poll that came out
at the same time it shows that biden's
lead has been sliced it's an ibd tipp
poll and shows that it's within three
points which is basically margin of
error but nobody's reporting that
i find that so strange like why do the
people in the news decide that one poll
which is
ways heavily to dems is more important
meanwhile in the post debate
the percentage of registered voters who
switched 19 did
percent went to trump and eight percent
went to joe biden
so there's your polls that you're not
going to hear about it right
about one poll is quite credible and i'm
sure about it wasn't the one you
mentioned
no it was the only one yeah that was
actually more accurate than the
time yeah let's let's just go to the
professionals on that point but dagon i
just wanted to
perform about biden on the campaign
trail because
jesse says he put a lid on early but i
think he was pretty respectful they
pulled down the negative ads
what do you think uh how do you if
you're the opponent how do you handle
a moment like this he needs to sway
voters
on the economy in that wall street
journal poll that he is
leading in with 14-point lead president
trump still leads on his handling of the
economy
48 to 41 joe biden pledged to eliminate
all
president trump's tax cuts how are you
going to make the case to the american
people oh i'm going to raise taxes on
your employers
so they pay you less or maybe don't
bring you back from furlough
i think that he needs to address that a
well-known pollster
texted me earlier and said this go
around we don't have really good numbers
and polling on enthusiasm
but we do know a couple of things
one-third of biden voters are voting
for joe biden but 70 percent of trump
voters are voting
for trump therein lies the enthusiasm in
an election where people might be
reticent to get out and vote in public
that could make the difference for
president trump